right now joining us from NBC sports
Chicago whose post and reporting with
the Jerry Krause unpublished and final
excerpt from his unpublished and
unfinished memoirs from from which I was
quoting liberally over the last 15
minutes we appreciate Casey Johnson of
NBC Sports Chicago joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show of bulls and Sutter
and somebody's been covering this team
for quite some time
how are you Casey I'm well how are you
I'm doing fine I you know in my if you
will take on the final episode of the
last dance was informed quite a bit from
the fact that I read your post from over
the weekend that Jerry Krause in his
memoir and is unpublished and unfinished
memoir put a lot of details on the end
of the Bulls that may or may not have a
bias to it but it is something that I
didn't hear last night so I want to give
you the floor here on this memoir and
what you thought of the ending of last
night's last dance well I was working
for the Chicago Tribune back then I
covered the second three feet along with
several other leaders for the Tribune
side I feel like I covered it from a
journalistic aspect back then I mean I
think when you handed three examples a
dynasty there are multiple factors that
play there's no simple one black and
white reason I mean there were multiple
reasons why the one ended when it did
what I try to do with with these
excerpts was just give Jerry a floor and
give his perspective a sat a time when
obviously he's not able to do so since
he passed away in 2017 so this to me
wasn't really journalism this was more
just kind of you know throwing out his
perspective and he gave a very detailed
reason why he felt the dynasty needed to
break up I thought that in terms of
tying it to the documentary Jerry
Reinsdorf elucidated some of the same
reasons that basically they felt that
with an aging core you know to run it
back would have been really expensive
and not sure that it would produce a
championship given how well you know
that 97 Knight 98 team had a feeling
that was said
I can say just having better on that
team you know covering it I felt the
same way that that team to me felt like
a team that was kind of reaching its
limit so why did the team get broken up
Casey why but well I mean you know it
got broken up because Scottie Pippen was
prior to being underpaid and getting all
this trait that got broken up because
Bill Johnson burn crosses relationship
had deteriorated to the point where Phil
needed a break it it got broken up
because the Bulls felt that Dennis
Rodman was wayward and could not be
reeled back in he played 35 more games
every endeavor they got broken up
because Luc Longley his body was about
to break down it got broken up because
Jerry Krause wanted the chance to
rebuild and not bottomed out which
unfortunately ended up happening I mean
he really felt that's why she tried to
trade Scottie Pippen in 97 to the
Celtics to draft recent agreement on
Mercer and and kind of fast start the
rebuilt during serve mix that deal so
you know when there's a break dynasties
are hard for if they don't happen pretty
hot curry and when there's that many
strong personality and you know people
in play it just kind of comes to an end
and you know I understand Michael
sentiment that you wanted to be taken
away from him and lose it on the court I
understand that he's open to competitor
you know that 98 Conference final
against the Pacers was an incredibly
tough series so would have any would
have been able to squeeze one more out
we'll never know but I can tell you this
around being on that 97-98 team it had
had a few of the finality to it well
were you surprised in DC last night
Jordan say that he would have he would
have run it back one more time and that
that everybody would have except that
Scottie would need as he said some
convincing but he would have handled
I mean what would you were you surprised
to hear that last night oh because I
feel like a whiz I mean that's been you
know that was abundantly clear then and
it's been made abundantly clear again
with this documentary that you know
Michael believes he can will things into
existence she's the greatest athlete and
competitor I've ever been her in and
most people have ever seen so of course
he's gonna believe that I personally I'm
glad you least acknowledge the
difficulty the Scottie thing because I
can tell you you know the center on the
team was it Scottie was on the first
train smokin you know out of town and
you know when the lockout ended he's on
with the Rockets and the agents came to
the Bulls and asked to structure a
sanitary so you get paid more money
which the Bulls did to give him a
going-away present so I think Scottie
you know lucky he delayed the night the
third ring before the 97-98 doctor
because he was just you know angry and
there was a feeling that you know he was
he was done and so certainly was done I
mean you know Hills said that in his
books he said that it's time you know
you can parse the reasons why he was
gone but he also had a theory you know
you stay in one place for seven years
and then you kind of the team needs a
new voice he's that theory with the
Lakers as well not just the Bulls
he stayed nine with the Bulls because
they kept winning championships so again
this is all I get was also singing and
you know this was covered ad nauseam and
enunciate and it's just obviously brings
you through this prism of this
documentary and and the pet pandemic
with which we're living it I know and it
was a remarkable documentary you know
Casey Johnson NBC Sports Chicago joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show and
everybody should check out the post that
he had of the excerpt from Jerry Krause
is unpublished unfinished memoir
describing why or how exactly the nuts
and bolts this is what I wanted to know
last night the exact dismantling of this
team and so what's the truth then Jerry
Krause telling Phil before the season
you can go 82 no doesn't matter you're
done or or crowd saying and is
unfinished unpublished memoirs
Phil said before the season eight months
before the breakup meeting that that
that Jerry Krause recounts that fills
the one who said I need a break I'm
going to Montana regardless of how this
goes what's the truth here between
agents Musburger were so contentious
that Jerry Reinsdorf had to fly to
Montana and save the day just to bring
Phil back for the 97-98 season still
side to three in the summer of 96 in the
summer of 97 so he was hanging on by a
frog it was on camera you said that
comment about the 82 and Oh
their relationship was badly
deteriorated there's no getting around
that but the other day to reinstall you
know whether you can parse whether it
was a genuine offer or not but he offers
Phil the opportunity in 98 to come back
Phil still chose not to take it and Phil
is on record who's Brooks and at the
time then saying he's not going to take
it so again why did that happen
because he felt me to bring Ponte could
be felt like his theory of staying in
place for seven seasons had been
extended nine season probably because of
his deterioration deteriorate attending
relationship with hearing kress again
there's no simple answers on your visit
the dynasty ran its course for multiple
reasons everybody's got their own
perspective as to why it happened to me
that the truth lies you know kind of
always a little so I guess what's don't
work let me use the you know now I know
why perhaps I didn't get a clear-cut
answer and at the end of the the
documentary last night but I still
wanted some sort of full-on nuts and
bolts accounting similar to what I got
here from from Jerry Krauss's memoir so
then let me ask you Casey to use the few
good men reference here if Santiago was
ordered not to be touched why was he
touched
who ordered the code
who was the first one to say this is
over how did that happen
after the last dance when when Jerry
says he went to Phil to say let's do
this one more time and we obviously
don't know the circumstances under that
he didn't mention the word rebuild in
his conversation with Jason hair on last
night's documentary how did it who is
the one to basically say we're done now
in Chicago Phil said no I mean Jerry
Reinsdorf offered him the chance to come
back that would Michael in 98 what a
lockout starting with Chopin look before
you make a decision let me talk to Phil
and what the Phil and often the shares
come back and so said it's time it's my
time to go
you said that to us on the record as
pulled off on a motorcycle in the booths
in a parking lot I was there it's my
time to go though because you can
understand why I feel the point
there's no it's a multi-layered answer
is I guess what I'm trying to get at but
if you're if you're asking what the
Domino is genuine Cerf offers Phil
Jackson the chance to return and still
said no so you can I mean see in 90s in
97 you went out to Montana and I just
say those going to bring about he was
successful in 97 it was not successful
in 98 so I don't that answers your
question but no I think on the preceding
no I guess I guess it does but we just
don't know the circumstances under which
I guess did Phil and Michael ever have a
conversation where Phil's just like yeah
we can only come back if the if it's you
and no Scotty um and I don't know what's
left with Rodman you know like that's
the sort of stuff I wanted to hear you
know Kukoc was still there like you and
Kukoc and me you know in a season that I
don't know if it's gonna happen you know
like I would love to be a fly on that
wall if that conversation ever took
place Casey you know
[Music]
to attend part documentary and just the
breakup of the dynasty I mean I feel
like as great as this film was it was
you know ultimately it was more of a
historic history lesson it's me more
with Jordan right critically it was
wonderful filmmaking was captivating
watch and certainly needed it in this
time we're all living it but you know to
me it just really kind of got to the
break-up at the very end I think you
could not ten hours but certainly
multiple hours on that and so these
questions you're you're asking you know
I would like to know some of the answers
inside like I reported a question some
of the stuff that happened back then I
don't know the feeling you don't know
what kind of private conversations took
place back then in terms of hey what you
gonna do I mean Michael is pretty
adamant that he could have got the band
back together ever put anything down we
all know that oh no doubt Casey Johnson
NBC Sports Chicago here on the Rich
Eisen show a few more minutes left with
him how about the revelation that it
wasn't the flu game it was the food
poisoning game did you learn that for
the first time last night - Casey we
news/bad pizza so we we that's been
written about her for years so that that
was not new to me I mean the five
delivery guy can Grover was quoting an
ESPN article in 2012 saying that I'm not
sure that they were like you know
pulling out a bottle of hemlock
endoscopy to it that that might be able
to conspiracy theorists for for my face
but uh but no we knew we know it was
pizza for four years you know I didn't
learn much in this because I was you
know I considered myself kind of a Bulls
historian you know I've been around the
franchise for a long time I did not know
about for the sixty three point game and
I loved that anecdote and I the Brian
Russell story until if I did know what I
forgot it about how Brian Kennedy missed
him when he went to retire and go play
baseball so I complete that little
clunky mutable approach
I know cuz Russell didn't sit down it
seems like Stockton was the only jazz to
sit down and I saw to that you know
people you know obviously Twitter
there's trolls saying that you know that
Karl Malone didn't sit down for this
that there's hard feelings I've ever
eaten how about the footage of him going
on the bus and shaking hands with Jordan
you know the exact opposite of the
Pistons never shaken Jordans hands after
losing to Jordan on the court and this
guy after getting denied a second time
went onto the bus found him and shook
his hand that was something if any yeah
that's a fantastic point I actually
really liked rich episodes 9 of 10
because I thought there was a little bit
more but this behind the scenes footage
he had that wonderful anecdote where
Jordan's talking smack the Larry Bird
after only eight finals and you know
obviously we're in the business how you
know you see those behind it seems like
other sausage made guys waiting for
their press conference turn in the
bowels of the stadium and just the
banter between them I thought that stuff
was fantastic last night and I also
enjoyed your star turn that was good
stuff and by the way you are an
excellent wordsmith clearly Casey when
you refer to what Michael said to bird
as quote-unquote a wonderful anecdote
that's one way to put it we saw oh my
gosh that's that's the ultimate you know
what into chicken salad that you just
made right there yeah so it was
remarkable and you know I I just wanted
a fin ative answer at the end of this
and the fact that we still did not get
one makes me think that it's gotta be
out there somewhere that there is a
morsel on the floor that we we have not
placed in front of us you know then the
question is is they you know in a
shortened season the next year they if
they had run it back you know if they
had run it back they could have won a
fourth in a row and its seventh out of
nine Casey well I'll close of this it's
like it's like
you know now we're playing the holy
water scheme because you know
also Michael suffered a pretty serious
injury during the lockout with a cigar
cutter sliced a tendon in the finger
deep you know obviously I thought maybe
he's not gonna be using this power
cutter in the Bahamas if you know as the
teams getting run back during the
lockout maybe years
oh you're speculating on to other things
and Michael availability would have been
a question for the full 1999 season with
the wood that cigar cutter injury so
again another layer - I don't know I'm
just I just I just wanted an answer I
thought that we were gonna get it it's
not the fault of Jason hair it's just
that again I thought that by the end of
this like the last half hour last 45
minutes would be all about the
relitigate of the end game here
certainly since everybody was sat down
pretty much for the exception of Kraus
and I'm appreciative that you got this
last question for you how did you get
your hands on
on the Kraus memoir that was unpublished
unfinished Casey well I covered him for
six seasons for the Chicago Tribune and
then once you hooked up with him to do
like an exit interview which was a
painful day for him because he loved the
job so much and a trust built and then
when he returned to his first love of
baseball scouting which is good for the
last 14 years of his life or 13 years of
his life just kind of a natural
friendship for me I was no longer
professionally obligated to cover him he
was someone who was very curious and
wanted to stay in the game of basketball
you would call me we would talk on the
phone constantly he was someone who just
wanted somebody to listen to him and
listening is what I do for a living so a
friendship just kind of naturally formed
and I've gotten to know his family very
well and they're incredibly gracious to
share these writings with me again I
don't I didn't give them a journalism I
view them as just throwing them out
there and run giving somebody a voice at
a time when he was not able to offer
that well done Casey at Casey j-hoop for
anybody that wants to see
case the the memoir that I'm referring
to or follow anything that Casey Johnson
is doing really appreciate this
conversation Casey thank you appreciate
you calling in I enjoyed it rich poor
care about right back at you you got it
cuts Casey Johnson
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here